[Music]
all right y'all this article is
definitely for Nick oh cool Nick Nick
why is that someone die huh Nick theck
that's what you think we want for you
dude that that's what every time it is
every time you're like Nick's Ryan's
like every time uh he has an article he
goes Nick's going to love this one three
parents three uh couples of parents died
in plane crash or something I don't know
I tried to figure it out three parents
three couples of parents three couples
of parents died
in yeah I I picked it cuz you like math
quizzes three uh three kids got punched
in the face by three couples of people
died so uh Netflix is being called out
uh over the name of their new dating
show featuring people with Down Down For
Love it's a [__] up name kind of why
is it why is it [__] up I don't know I
just feel like they couldn't choose a
better name cuz you watch it cuz look I
started watching last night with with my
lady and it's a really cute show it's
really sweet cuz you dive into their
relationship you dive into who they are
as a you get to meet their whole family
they're all from New Zealand and then
you get and then you hear them talk
about love right and you realize that
like oh yeah love is such a necessity
for humans to be able to connect and you
forget that like they really long for
love too like people with Down syndrome
and then it's hard for them to meet
people forget
that you really going to [__] me over
like that you really just going to do
that to me right now so what would the
name Why would the name be so bad it's a
pun on down syndrome there could be
worse things than that you they could
have like what down a clown
like he was waiting for that one yeah he
was I say that a lot though what is it
called down for love sweetheart
sweetheart no it's a really he's really
cute bro like I really like wow in but I
really like
or very bad have you guys seen love on a
spectrum so that's not that title is not
considered offensive well I don't know
people just get mad over every is that
the same premise true uh people autism
oh that one was really cute too cuz it's
like very pure very sweet and you're
like a is so cute do you think they're
mad cuz they're just like trying to put
down syndrome people in a certain light
like so that people could laugh or
whatever react to this thing because of
that label does it is I think that's
what people assume that's what the
show's about but then it's an actual
when you watch it it's very different
right like but I think I think people
with Down Center don't get mad at the
title I think it's everyone else that
gets mad right right at it yeah because
it's like cuz what if they're happy that
there's a show like showcasing it's a
different light on these people you know
yeah I think it's I think it's there
there is no they're just mad cuz they
wanted to watch the show and laugh at
them and N what the [__] is this it's
too good yeah they're like I wanted to
watch out I wanted to watch a bunch of
downies do something fun downies you is
that an accepted term yeah there's a
restaurant in Germany that one of my
clients was telling me about it's called
downies and brownies and I think the
whole staff is down CER y oh oh wow it
looks really
fun did they get cancell too or no I'm
sure people were upset at the name like
I'm sure if you look at the comments on
their post I'm sure they they'll have
some people fight unless they came up
with the name themselves yeah that's the
other thing too like you can't get mad
at that right yeah if they came up with
it that's true yeah and they're working
they're you know that'd be like I
started a Chinese restaurant I call
myself yellow face yeah like mad at that
right like I did it I'd be a little mad
Asians would still be mad at me for no
reason neck shark would be mad at you
for sure and then Joe would be in the
comments
quick supporting them there is there is
that perspective though that like you
you know um this is like there's the
role of these disabled stars is to
entertain able-bodied viewers or even
make them feel
better I think there's definitely people
that are going to think that but when I
watch it I just think it's just
interesting to see how they date and see
how like it I don't know I I didn't get
that Vibe at all like when I watched it
I just thought it was it was just really
sweet like I don't know yeah it you feel
like it was like insightful yeah 100%
like to see how they go through it and
then like everyone in their family seems
really supportive of like trying to help
them push and date you know cuz dating
is hard for [__] you know for
everybody so and I would imagine the
pool of people that they could date is
and they talk about that the the people
one of the girls with Down Syndrome I
think her name was Libby or something
she's talking about how it's hard to
date other people down syndrome because
the spectrum of I guess conversation
they have or the level of communication
that they have is all varied so it's
hard for them to meet up and communicate
and actually find the love that they're
looking for yeah so I thought that was
interesting it seems kind of like a
stupid thing for people to say like oh
that's for Able Body people to like
watch or like to look at it like there's
some type of privilege yeah because
every dating show is like that you're
not like the people that you're watching
yeah you're objectively smarter than
they are most of the time like for
instance when you watch that show um
Love is Blind have you guys seen that
one they pretty much the whole thing the
whole premise of the show is they they
stand behind a wall and they talk to
each other and they don't know what they
look like you see the silhouette though
right yeah then they get Mar then they
they're like we're going to I want to
see this person real life we're going to
get engaged and they like they ask them
to marry them or some [__] they engage
before they even see each other and then
they see each other and then they and
then they follow the train wreck bro
that's what it really yeah right they
either like most of them don't make it
out of their own that seems way worse
like changing their lives the whole
premise of the show is they follow them
in their engagement and
then when they get married they make
their final yes or no so they invite
both families they have a whole wedding
ceremony and then they stand up at the
altar in front of everybody and they go
will you take so and so as your wife or
husband and sometime and most of the
time someone says no while other person
is like ready to get married in front of
the whole family so it's like you're
setting these people up to fail but is
it good TV oh it's [__] good TV good
content [__] good TV well people
don't mind making fun of trash but they
get really sad when you make fun of
people with disability but that's the
thing they're not making fun of them so
those people that are getting mad
they're like they haven't even seen the
show that's the thing is like I wonder
if they even really saw it they're
judging a book by its cover well that's
that's what's weird is like they're
they're watching Love island or Bachelor
and talking so much [__] about those
people yeah it's like yeah at least
you're not talking [__] at least you're
enjoying so my favorite one of my
favorite shows is my gypsy wedding
what's that it's a show about the Gypsy
culture oh and and and them getting
married D it's pretty good as long as
it's real I appreciate it yeah not like
the [__] where Amish people go out of
town and and do [__] in the city that
was fake yeah really you're not really
Amish yeah it was all like fake really
dude you know what would be crazy if
they made like uh what is it they're
setting up these people for failure cuz
you know like the love is blind they're
basically setting there's a train right
right cuz that's the entertainment it
would be [__] up if did that with Down
Syndrome people well it might evolve to
that I think it starts off it's going
down it probably starts off like all
innocent they're like we need better
ratings yeah and it goes crazier and
crazier I think once it gets to that
point if they're starting to take
advantage of them and stuff then it's
like okay now you can get mad but what
if what if it creates the Kim Kardashian
of the Down Syndrome world what would
her name be I don't cardian [__] is this
not right he said downies yeah he said
that earlier I didn't play in that realm
I didn't play in that realm I didn't
play there you know what the difference
is it's like it's like when you compare
a documentary about mental health versus
a prank show where they prank
schizophrenics
right yeah exactly but it's the same
thing essentially the subjects are the
same but one is like paying respect to
them and showing how they really are and
like letting you walk away with a more
positive framing the other one is just
turning them into piñatas and smacking
[__] one's got to be done in
Japan the the it all goes down in Japan
for sure the first one is not going to
work but like when you watch it you just
see like the whole family is behind them
they're all part of the process they're
trying to help them how to date that's
cool yeah like I don't know I just think
it's it's more insightful than anything
else like does it feel like the mission
is to relate to them better like to walk
away with a better feel just to just to
kind of watch the process I guess I
don't I think there's nothing wrong with
them having a stake in the game like let
them be in the game let them be one of
the girls that was on the show she was
in like a movie she's like a movie star
do for like down syndrome like it was
about a girl who has Down syndrome who's
like learning how to date like a regular
dude or something like that and her
having her life and they talk about that
so it's like they want they want to be
as normal as everyone else you sound
like you watch a lot of down syndrum
content love content now my wife watches
it and I just sit in and I watch her for
a little bit and I go what the [__] is
this [__] what's your favorite one her
no yours
mine I really like um down for love
right now well I watched like 30 minutes
of it last time it's really good I like
I loved it I loved it for the first like
30 minutes I could my mind can change
after everybody do your homework watch
it we'll we'll come back and see what we
think and see if is really good too my
my first I've never seen 90 days yeah
it's good but now it's getting a little
weirder but the first I think the
episodes in the beginning haven't seen
the current seasons but the I've watched
like whole Seasons before they were
really good when my wife was watching
Love is Blind I was like this is
interesting right and then you watch it
and then you see like what's the payoff
and the payoff is the wedding scene
because that's when all the [__] hits
the fan and you watch it you go they're
[__] these people over and then you
see the reunion right and that's even
crazier it's just like why are they
these people trying to rush this whole
situation you know but I don't know yeah
dude well you also have to think that
some of them are doing it just to be on
TV oh yeah there's one guy put fake
tears in his eyes there's like a veil
that gets lifted once you realize oh
yeah it's just TV you know they want
fame MH yeah that's what a lot of it is
too that is what even 90 days producers
know how to pick them 90 days the same
way they they they fabricate a lot of
the stories on the Fly for some of
them